well
[Music
] former las
vegas' rangers player henry road is behind bars and
had his first court this morning
how are you greeted by cristian casseres with
super informative news now in spanish
road is facing charges of driving
under the  influence of
toxic substances that resulted in the death of a
person after an accident at the intersections
of rainbow and flamingo the detectives
say that world collided with another
vehicle from behind the other car ended up
in flames with a person dead inside the
unknown is not yet known  Identity of the
victim For their part, the raiders
announced that Watch no longer belongs to the
team days after being fired
by the school district's board of directors,
Dr. Jesús Jara reported that he
had given salary increases to several
district executives, including the
head of  finances among others the
raises add up to more than 400 thousand dollars
his last day of work is scheduled
for the first of December and the
search  to replace it is about to
start
and I tell you that the
neuro technology company has begun
construction of its new factory here in
las vegas the company has plans to
produce autonomous vehicles that will be
used to deliver food,
medicine, among other custom services, they
also hope to generate 200
jobs for the nord las vegas region
and the company is anticipated to generate more
than 2.2 billion dollars in the
next 10 years and the
pleasant temperatures continue for
today we take a look at the forecast
we can see that we can reach
almost  80 degrees for today
really hot days for the rest of
the week and don't forget that this
weekend you will have to turn the clock back an hour
I'm cristian casseres with his
brief news report on news now espanyol
good morning
[Music]